jennifer aniston reveals why she refuses
to use
dating apps what do i do with that
information now the morning show star
gets candid in a new interview with
instyle magazine
and opens up about why she just can't
get down with dating apps
specifically raya a high-end
invitation-only dating app
that is used by lots of public figures
and celebrities
quote here's the thing these so-called
anonymous places where so-called
well-known people can go
i guess the reason well-known people go
is because the people in the well-known
areas don't discuss well-known people
please no yeah so that sounds like a
hard no from jen
well we'll find out and when the mag
asks the friend star who has the best
red carpet pose in hollywood
she gave props to another gen jennifer
lopez
quote i want to know what gives her the
look like she's about to be seething
it's amazing she's almost stuck getting
mad at somebody but
she's just so gorgeous she's like i
can't believe i'm standing here
but i don't think she's trying she fell
out of bed that way
she's a performer i'm thrilled and she
has a point
just check out jlo on the red carpet
looking as aniston
said mad yet gorgeous seething yet
amazing
it almost doesn't feel like work but
back to jen aniston
good stuff though the actress who
started her career in the late 80s opens
up about the way the media treated stars
back in the day
specifically during the 90s saying that
the press fed on quote
young impressionable girls jen adds that
she was quote
lucky enough to have been raised by a
strict mom
quote the priorities were not about
becoming a famous person
it was study your craft learn what
you're doing don't just go out there and
get lucky i think that britney spears's
group of girls as teens didn't have
any kind of who am i they were being
defined by this
outside source the media took advantage
of that
capitalized on them and it ultimately
cost them their sanity
it's so heartbreaking but it wouldn't be
an interview with jen without a little
friend's talk
but if time was what you needed just to
gain a little perspective
we were on that break
fluffy house the 52 year old actress
dishes on the long-awaited friends
reunion special
and reveals what it taught her it was a
unicorn of an experience
for whatever reason we were all at the
right place
at the right time and we created
something that landed its little flag
on a lot of people's hearts around the
world and all that echoes what jen told
et
shortly after filming wrapped for the
hbo max special which aired in may
all i can say is that there was
something that was
laid down at the very very beginning
that kind of went into our neural
pathways that we
instantly it was in our dna that we were
family we were going to take care of
each other
it's unexplainable but we're the most
grateful
women that i know who have been able to
be a part of something like this
you